you sometimes piece you you you work
with people like I did a movie with
Michelle Yeoh you know that is yes from
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
nice lady nice lady but the first night
I'm there I was in Thailand for two
months shooting this movie and I'm
meeting Michelle yeah I'm like this is
cool
and we're eating everything's fine with
some of the executives of the front of
movie whatever and then I I go I won't
go home on a good job so I go hey
Michelle um later after dinner he teach
me how to run on trees right and she
looks at me beat she goes angrily why I
walk I thought that she actually knew
how to [ __ ] do that and I went yeah I
know it's work and then you know what
else happened so now I leave the table
because in our table is the tile and the
royal family the president of Samsung
right and Michelle Yao and all the other
actors and we're in the table now
there's other tables around our table
with all the like assistants and the
young people yeah so I get up from the
table like a [ __ ] this [ __ ] table
where did you go I went to hung out with
like the guys with the Mohawks and the
suits you mean like yeah me the preppy
cool kids yeah I'm [ __ ] around with
them and then an executive from the
movie he grabs my arm as hard as he can
he pulls me away and he goes you big
ruled right and pulls me back into the
big table right then I have to apologize
the president of Samsung and it was like
I'm sorry that what I'm sitting there
and then I got yelled at for cuz the
shirt I wore this is it's the four
seasons the shirt I wore wasn't a shirt
it was ripped okay so it had the you
know the ring or the t-shirt that had
the ring around it right but half of it
was gone with you so you could just see
half of my torso
my left arm it's completely out was the
thought process it just got ripped it
was hot it got ripped rip yeah so I
showed up like we did one sleeve on yeah
oh that's yeah and my jeans were sagging
so my pubes are showing I'll just walk
in you know mean um I was that also I
got kind of like you can't you can't do
that yeah and then I'll tell you the
last thing that happened because I've
never told this story before okay so I
show up shooting this movie and so I
don't have a trailer okay so Michelle
Yeoh obviously has a gigantic double
banger thing right and then there's a
kid that's the star in it named henry
lau he's a huge Korean pop star mm-hmm
and I used to like sleep in his he let
me sleep in his thing right right but
one day I just said [ __ ] I got crazy
you're there for two months
yeah yeah like a month in I'm like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] mosquitoes I'm
sitting there you know me with the other
extras go [ __ ] yes so I called my agent
the worst move I could have made really
horse move yes sir check this out what
is what happened been day my agent finds
out about he calls Korea because it's
not an American movie just all of Korea
gets a call
yeah the president oh he called um CJ
entertainment you know any [ __ ] rips
them an [ __ ] it's like this kid you
know I'm flying is a list so then they
gave me and two other actors one trailer
that's fine air conditioning but the
Thai crew stopped talking to me know
every time I walk by a Thai crew they're
going on here come mr. Hollywood farting
his agent everything
you know mr. Hollywood I need a trailer
when we don't have the budget to do it
and no and I was out Wow yeah so anyway
let that be a lesson
yeah that also happened and okay
sensitive subject did happen on
pineapple Express to you manager
demanded and then he got cut out of the
movie oh man regrets we all learn that's
how I got cut out
oh okay well I listen I apologize to
when I'm when I was shooting love that
the head ad was one at one time was the
ad during that other party scene what we
did at that one place right that lady
she did pile of Express and I literally
walked up to her and I apologize for my
behavior on a couple Express Ken and I
had the same part ken Jeong we're but
henchman or whatever but he got a
trailer and I didn't at the time I had
done seven years on MADtv and I had done
a couple of movies you know me my
hangover no oh no hangover at that point
ah so in my head I'm like [ __ ] this guy
get a trailer in making a phone call to
my agent was the worst move I've ever
made in my life
yeah so anyway let that be a lesson to
never complain all you young talk are
call your agent over you sit there and
you get bit by mosquitoes and you take
it Chris
you never complained because at the end
of the day it's like the reason it's not
a personal reason why I don't get a
trailer is because we have so many
people here and we're trying to juggle
with so many balls can you just not have
a trailer right and just say outside
it's also hard not to take it personally
especially when you feel like you've
worked you had just gotten off something
for seven years you know I could see
where you're coming from to but I mean
every Mexican teenager in America knows
it is true yeah that's right you really
should add that to your actual like
resume
[Music]